from the director of deuce Bigalow male
gigolo comes trolls a new animated film
based off of the good luck trolls the
dolls from when I was a little boy my
sisters had some of those I recall those
figures giving me nightmares
so trolls is the latest toy turned into
a hopeful franchise and this film is
about Anna Kendrick who plays poppy and
Justin Timberlake who plays branch poppy
gets all of her trolls captured by the
evil Bergin's Bergin's are these big
creatures that reside over the trolls
who believe that the only way to find
happiness is to eat a troll the trolls
flee and run and hide from them and
poppy and branch have to team up to go
and find the rest of the trolls who are
stuck in the Bergen town and free them
from their oppression and along the way
they're going to sing a lot of famous
pop songs too because Justin Timberlake
and Anna Kendrick voice these characters
so what else did you expect look we live
in a point now or everything that was
ever a thing is gonna be a movie it's
just gonna happen
we've already had transformers GI Joe
max steel this year that one really
worked out
I mean I'm fully convinced that at some
point we're going to get Combe the movie
the true story about combs and how they
hate greasy hair or the horrifying true
story of pencils and their evil enemy
the sharpener I mean there's even a
Barbie movie in development right now
everything that was ever a thing it's
gonna be a movie guys so is this movie
good is it terrible gratefully it is not
terrible I actually sat through this
movie and I was fine watching it it's a
perfectly okay one time watch for an
adult
I think young kids are gonna get a huge
kick out of this movie it has a lot of
really bright colors a lot of jokes that
kids are going to appreciate and like
for adults though this is more of a
strictly kids experience ever since the
lego movie was successful we're going to
get a lot of movies like this and a lot
of movies are going to try to take an
obscure product like that and make it
into a franchise I saw this movie with
my wife tonight and it was fine we could
watch it and as adults we were able to
laugh sometimes when characters just
randomly
sit out singing because we had no idea
it was gonna be a musical and that kind
of changed everything because I was just
like oh this is gonna be an entertaining
animated oh everyone singing now Justin
Timberlake is playing a troll that
doesn't like singing
I wonder if Justin Timberlake is ever
going to sing in the movie there are two
things about this movie that I find very
good number one the art styling it is a
very colorful movie the animation is
very vibrant it really leaps off the
screen it honestly felt like an LSD trip
very psychedelic imagery a lot of times
you're just kind of watching it like am
I stuck in the weird side of YouTube
right now and there is a great message
for kids involving acceptance of who you
are and how to attain happiness and the
fact that you don't always need certain
things to be happy kids are going to
appreciate this movie it's a film that
I'm sure parents can show to their kids
and say here guys sit down and watch
this movie and you know don't talk for
90 minutes please please we want to
sleep and I can sit here and say that oh
well you know you're being too harsh on
it Chris because this movie isn't made
for you it's made for kids but I try to
shy away from saying that in my reviews
of animated movies for families because
to me that's an easy way out for the
filmmakers the idea that you don't
necessarily have to give your all to a
script or to the direction of a
children's movie just because you know
that a lot of kids are going to see it
and they're going to be less judgmental
is in my opinion not a very good mindset
to have so we actually do go into a
family movie with a similar mindset that
I would for someone who's making a film
that's more mature I think that it's
important to really foot maybe even more
important to focus on those kind of
things for a kids movie because these
movies are going to be infecting the
children's minds and so you really want
to make them as good as they can be and
overall I respect them for trying but in
the long run I can't help but look past
the fact that this is really just
another attempt to take some product and
turn it into a movie that has a
recognizable name and build a story
around it and try to make it into a
successful franchise and to me it's not
really necessary they didn't bring it
home lego movie brought it home that
movie was clever and witty and very well
directed this movie is fine and I think
young possibly elementary school-age
kids will
to get a kick out of it but everyone
else is probably gonna be like alright
well I watched it I hope I never have to
see that again I'm going to give trolls
a see guys thank you very much for
watching please do check out my reviews
for hacksaw Ridge as well as Doctor
Strange and I'm going to have a surprise
review for you guys this weekend
you guys are the best thank you very
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]
you